[Music]
I've asked a lot about best travel
destinations where do I recommend people
check out and this is a difficult
question to answer but I'm gonna give it
a shot I'm gonna name a few of my
favorite spots that I have visited
number one would be assuming let's just
say that you're in the US but even not
if you want to visit a spot in the US
and there are many that are perhaps
unique even odd in comparison to other
places but very very fun New Orleans
I would highly recommend it is a
combination of cultural culinary
influences that come from seemingly
almost every corner of the world the
national parks so I would suggest people
if they have not visited the national
parks or perhaps they visited one or two
when they were younger make a point of
getting on the calendar at least one I
think that Zion is incredible Yosemite
certainly is just beyond belief and
there are many many others but you can
take your pick outside of the u.s. few
options if you are for instance
interested in parking up for a period of
time and the longer you stay in a
particular location outside of the US
the cheaper it will be your primary
expenses I think it's fair to say are
going to be in shorter trips airfare and
hotels if you're staying in hotels
you're going to be paying top dollar per
night
Argentina spent nine months in Argentina
around 2004 2005 after I plan to be
there for four weeks that really fell in
love with it it is a large country it is
a very long country and you can't find
everything from tropical rainforests
like Equus of Falls and Brazil all the
way down to incredible glaciers and
killer whales and penguins way way south
have you got to say see how they wiggle
and you are as close to Antarctica as
you really possibly be without being in
Antarctica next up if you want to go
remote if you're looking for a
combination of safety and English I
would recommend going to New Zealand and
of course there are many different
options for english-speaking places that
are fun
but go to the South Island of New
Zealand get a car and drive your way
down to Queenstown which is the
adventure sport capital of New Zealand
it's where they filmed a lot of Lord of
the Rings where you find the remarkable
mountain range and you can do such crazy
insane stuff as boogie-boarding and
Rapids which I tried and quite frankly
was more one of the more terrifying
experiences I've ever had a lot of that
so if you like ATVs adventure sports
it's incredible and it's very very
beautiful it looks quite a lot like
certain parts of Switzerland it's just
stunning and people are very very
friendly if you want to get a feel for
what New Zealanders are like at least
some of them you can watch flight of the
conchords all right let's look at a very
very safe and of course bad things can
happen anywhere okay and they do but
very very safe generally and non English
super alien environment what is the best
combination of feeling completely lost
bewildered in a foreign alien
environment and safety that I've
experienced has to be Japan and I spent
a year in Japan my first time really out
of the US as an exchange student going
to a Japanese school in Tokyo which was
huge culture shock living with a
Japanese family and Tokyo is just so
awesome and so weird that it's hard to
find words to express exactly what it
does like and there's no need
you should go it is not gonna be cheap
you can do it at moderate expense though
and it can be the trip of a lifetime
then I would say and this depends
obviously person-to-person but take a
trip to where some of your ancestors are
from to be like oh this is where part of
my bloodline comes from make an effort
so if you are let's just say Korean
American you've never been to Korea go
to Korea so I would recommend like go
somewhere where if you trace your
bloodline back you actually have some
some genetic origins there that's that's
also a really cool trip and it can make
a real impact on you
you